[Music]
welcome baby jumbo
lost family hair no matter how small
nope that's not a young Tandy Newton
it's her mini-me daughter Nico Parker
the west-world star walked the red
carpet alongside her look-alike
fourteen-year-old at the London premiere
of Nico's new movie Disney's live-action
Dumbo on Thursday the mama daughter duo
looked stunning Newton in a gray
sequined dress with furry details and
silver heels Parker in a pale pink and
orange gown with her curls pulled back
in a low ponytail look at me
we're gonna bring your mama hi Nico
plays Millie in the movie she's the
daughter of Colin Farrell's character
holt
how familiar were you with Dumbo before
you got this movie had you watch the
animated film did you love it I've seen
it like consistently throughout my whole
childhood and my mom would always cry
baby mine met and I never like I never
got why until I watched it after I got
the part and I was like maybe I should
watch it again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and I watched it and then I cried
because I got what it was about and I
was like wow and I was really moved by
it in real life the team is Newton's
middle child with hubby director and
writer ol Parker both of your parents
work in the movies yeah so what kind of
advice
did they give you about taking on a role
like this being in a film one of the
leads of it I mean when it came to like
acting advice they didn't give me that
much which I really appreciate because I
wasn't like I think would really
overwhelming if they gave me this advice
because you know that both in the
industry and that can be a bit
intimidating but so especially from my
dad I think the main advice was be nice
to everyone because that's what I
remember
Parker also opened up to et at the LA
premiere of Dumbo my dad to direct right
away I just think it'll be fun and
dished about working in the family
business I wanted to be a dancer when I
was younger and then as I just got the
audition and then I started and then
loads of auditions and then I got the
part and then the film and then think a
weekend I was like this is what I want
to do now and this is I love this and
this is when I did and I think I wasn't
it's not I didn't want to follow her
footsteps we've never been like the
thing I wanted to do cuz I being on set
so much when I was younger and I never
really thought about it something I
could do and then as soon as I started
doing it myself
then it became kind of a reality like oh
you could actually do
[Music]